the rays who have already clinched a
post-season berth need a win or a yankee
loss tonight to clinch the american
league east title one-two coming
and a half-swing he went around strike
three and waka's got back-to-back
strikeouts to start the night bacca
struck out the first two
and he strikes out all three
michael walker starting with a bang
fanning the side in the opening inning
and the mets have two men on and now
alonso coming off a big night last night
against his hometown team and pete
strikes out on the curve ball and that's
the second strikeout for glasnow tom
smith with two out and two on
dom had a double last night
and he gets the swing on that breaking
ball
in the dark last now matches waka by
striking out three but he also gave up
a couple of base runners but no harm
well here is joey wendell
faces empty two gone wendell at 280 on
the year
wendell shoots it back into right field
mcneil's going to turn around and that
ball is out of here
home run wendell a line drive shot to
right
his fourth home run of the year and the
rays break out in front
right into his swing he caught that
flush in flushing
knocked out a cut cut out
put the raise on the board so with two
ounces of the base is empty here's
andres jimenez first pitch to jimenez
drilled in the air to deep right down
the line it is gone a home run
andres jimenez ties it with a home run
off the facing of the coca-cola corner
of the second deck andres jimenez with a
line drive home run to tie the game his
third big league home run and it was a
bullet 108 miles an hour off the bat and
jimenez ties the game at one
now brandon lau
13 home runs has two men out there in
scoring position
[Applause]
on the ground right side
throw to the plates not going to be in
time margot got that hand in there ahead
of the
tag by ramos and the rays take a 2-1
lead
2-1 tampa bay first and third one out
for a rose arena
and it's not hit deep cenino is a slow
runner mcneal getting under it
and zunina is going to try it here comes
the throw by mcneil on the hop rumbles
gets the tag down and it's in time to
get him
perfect throw by mcneil a one hop strike
and the mints do get it out at the plate
one batter after they missed and out at
home renfro flied to right his first
time
and he drills one to left dom coming on
sliding and he made the catch
great grab by dom who's made a couple of
sparkling plays out in left field
tonight and he robs renfrew of a base
hit for the second out good bead on this
ball good jump well done nice slide one
out nobody on here in the fourth as the
rays lead the mets two to one
here's the curve ball hit deep to right
and dom has tied the game
dom smith unloading well up into the
coca-cola corner up onto the tarp
number 10 for dom smith and it's 2-2
well glasnow may have a high whiff rate
on his curveball but not against dom
smith he got it up here this was a
hanger but dom as i mentioned earlier is
an outstanding
breaking ball hitter and that 12 to 6
curve ball the pitcher wants to get that
down in the strike zone and that's
throwing right into dom's strength
[Applause]
what out at one on now randy arose arena
who had a fly ball into a double play as
last time up rosarina sends a fly ball
deep into right center that one is gone
home run for rosarina on the first pitch
and the rays will grab the lead it's 4-2
number six for randy rosarina
and see you later breaking that tie well
alonso a couple of strikeouts last now
twice has gotten them on breaking balls
and a swing and a miss
alonso out on strikes and a nice
shutdown inning by tyler glasnow in the
sixth
wow drove it around with the fielder's
choice in the third
3-1 swung out and skied down the right
side
that ball is well hit is a fair ball
and is out of here
brandon loud turns on a 3-1 pitch headed
down the line and kept it fair
and gives the raise two more runs
on his 14th home run of the year it's
now 6-2
[Applause]
that's a ground ball gonna go through
into center field
rosarina will score the run batted in
for willy adams
it's now a seven to two ball game
that's a long shot well hit deep is it
fair
that ball
was really tagged i'm telling you
what a shot for a home run
a rosarena hits his second home run of
the night
down the line
his seventh home run of the year and boy
did he
lay into that one
two outs now with a man in third one out
to get frazier gets a hold of one deep
to left a rosarina back looks up and
it's out of here
todd frazier with a two run homer his
fourth of the year
and now it's eight to five one out away
from clinching the american league east
there it is
he takes care of business
the tampa bay rays
when the american league east